شركه
البريطانيه هي اكبر شركه عامله في مجال
الصناعات الدفاعيه في المملكه المتحده كما
انها تعد ايضا واحده من كبرى الشركات
العامله في هذا المجال حول العالم حقق فقط
العام الماضي المرتبه السابعه بناء على
مبيعتها من الصناعات العسكريه
للكثير من دول العالم من بينها مثلا
الولايات المتحده التي تعتمد عليها بشكل
كبير في صدرتها العسكريه وكذلك العديد من
الدول حول العالم ومن هنا ومن بين هنا دول
في منطقه الشرق الاوسط التي تربطها شراكه
كبيره بهذه الشركه امتدت على مدى سنوات
حول رؤيه الشركه لهذه الشراكه والشركاتها
مع الدول المنطقه
وهو المستشار العسكري للشركه وايضا رئيس
اركان القوات الجويه البريطانيه بين عامي
2013 و2016 اولا سيرلاندي اهلا بك معنا في
عسكريتاريا يعني يبدا معك سؤال بناءا على
تاريخك السابقه انت كنت تيار في السابق
وقائد سابق في القوات الجويه الملكيه
البريطانيه اولا برايك ما هو النموذج
الامثل بالنسبه للمقاتلات الحربيه سواء
الان او في المستقبل
التي تبذلها بعض الشركات مثل بي اي سيستمز
لتقديم الطائرات المثاليه فما من شيء من
هذا القبيل الطيران من امثالي دائما
يرغبون في الحصول على طائرات اسرع قدره
تحليق اكثر سرعه وارتفاعا واكثر مقاومه
للجاذبيه والقاده العسكريون يرغبون في ان
تكون تلك الطائرات اكثر توفرا وان تكون
قابله للصيانه والاصلاح بصوره اكبر وان
تكون منخفضه التكلفه بحيث يمكن شرائها لذا
لابد للمرء ان ياخذ جميعها هذه العوامل في
الحسبان
ومحاولته فعل كل ما هو ممكن من اجل تقديم
الحلول الوسطى الممثله عند تسليم الطائرات
ذات القدرات ليست فقط القذره على تنفيذ
المهم النقطه بها فحسب بل يجب ضمانه
بتكلفه ميسوره قدر الامكان حتى يتسنى
شرائها وان تكون صيانتها سهله قدر الامكان
وضمان ان المنتج الذي تقدمه هو الافضل على
الاطلاق
سير عندي الكثير من الشركات العامله في
هذا المجال الان تقوم على تطوير طائرات من
الجيل السادس وانتم بالفعل لديكم في بيس
سيامز نموذج لطائره تسمى بس هو مشروع
مشترك كبير اولا اين وصل هذا المشروع وما
الذي سيجعله مميز عن بقيه نماذج اخرى من
طائرات الجيل السادس
سايتين
مثيره
ستقدم احدث ما توصلت اليه تكنولوجيا
الخدمات خلال العقد المقبل وفي الوقت
الحالي اننا في مرحله التقييم اذا بنظرنا
الى كل هذه الخيارات الخاصه بالطائرات
التي تشكل جزءا من المنظومات المرتبطه
بانظمه بي اي اي فاننا نتطلع لتسليم
طائرات ستكون في مرتبه الطليعه من حيث
التكنولوجيا والقدرات اذ ستكون ذات تصميم
عالميا
وبدانا بالعمل على تصميمها منذ البدايه مع
شركائنا الدوليين ونتطلع لانهاء الاتفاق
مع اليابان هذا العام وبكل تاكيد مع
ايطاليا التي تعد شريكان على الامل الطويل
وهذا امر مثير وخاصه انها ستكون
بتكنولوجيا رقميه محمله بقدر كبير من
البيانات منذ البدايه ولها قدرات اخرى
للعمل في البيئات التي تجتنفها التحديات
طلبت لكننا نسير في الاتجاه الصحيح سير
عندي فيما يتعلق بشراكه بي اس سيستمز مع
دول المنطقه
بيسستمز لديها تاريخ كبير مع دول هذه
المنطقه لكن الان هذه الدول تبحث عن
شراكات وليس فقط مجرد شراء معدات عسكريه
اولا كيف تقيمون الشراكه مع هذه الدول في
الوقت الحالي والى اي مدى باس ستنزل لديها
استعداد على التعاون مع دول هذه المنطقه
حتى تنهض بصناعتها الدفاع
المدني
في هذا الجزء من العالم فتره طويله من
الزمن واننا فخورون للغايه بعملائنا الذين
عملنا معهم على مر السنوات ولا طالما كان
مبدانا هو ان نكون شركاء وليس مجرد منتجي
ومقدم الخدمه بحيث نستطيع الوقوف على
متطلباتهم
بحيثون استطيع ان نسلم في الوقت المحدد
وضمن حدود التكل المتوقعه لدينا علاقه منذ
فتره طويله هنا في البحرين تعود جذورها
الى مطلع القرن الحالي
واننا نشعر بالفخر بانظمه التدريب التي
نقدمها بصوره عامه وعلاقتنا مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه تعد في الطليعه من حيث
العلاقه بين عميل المنتجات العسكريه ومزود
للصناعات الدفاعيه وهي علاقه مستمره ليس
فقط من خلال انظمه التدريب بل ايضا من
خلال برنامج التعاون الدفاعي السعودي
البريطاني ونرمي الاستكشاف افاق جديده لا
تقتصر على التدريب وتسليم الطائرات بحيث
نضمن اننا نفعل مابسنا وان جهودنا هناك
تتوافق مع خطط التوطين اذ ان سبعه 77
بالمئه من موظفي
سيستمز في السعوديه هم مواطنون السعوديون
وهي مساله لا تدعو للفخر بالنسبه الينا
فحسب
اعلم انها ستجعل الشعب السعودي يشعر
بالفخر ايضا ساير انديا الان الحرب في
اوكرانيا تدخل على عامها الاول لكننا لم
نلاحظ اي سيطره جويه سواء من الجانب
الروسي او حتى من الجانب الاوكراني وانت
لك خبره سابقه وكبيره في هذا المجال برايك
هل تعتقد بان هذا الامر بسبب المقاتلات
المستخدمه من الجانبين او الطائرات
المستخدمه من الجانبين ان يعود الى التيار
المستخدم لهذه المقاتلات او طائرات
[موسيقى]
عن اوكرانيا فانني اتحدث بصوره اساسيه
كقائد متقاعد للقوات الجويه وليس كم موظف
لدى بي اي سيستمز لكن انني اعتقد ان
الصراع في اوكرانيا قد اخذ الكثيرين على
حين غره وما كان يجب ان ينشب هذا الصراع
اصلا فنحن نتحدث عن بلدين دخل في تونس
صراع ولديهما قدرات متوازنه الى حد كبير
من نواحي العده لاننا اعتدنا على عمليات
يكون فيها لاحد الطرفين المتنازعين اليد
الطول في الحرب انجازات تعبير وتجد ان
احدهما لن يصعب عليه تحقيق مكاسب ومن ثم
الحفاظ على الاستقلاليه لكن الصوره مختلفه
في اوكرانيا واكله طرفين يتحارب بضراوه من
اجل الحصول على ميزه التفوق سواء كان ذلك
بصوره مؤقته
التفوق الجغرافي بحيث يكون لديهم خيار
انتقاء مناطق عملياتهم وهذا ليس امرا
مفاجئا وهذا ما يحدث عند الصراع بين
الاقران